hi guys I'm grace Helbig for those of
you who have recently just subscribed
which has been a fair amount of you due
in part to a grassy Michelle being
featured on stir-fried TV hey buddy hey
um hello I just have to let you know
that I haven't touched this channel for
about a year so which you've probably
noticed but I'm gonna start being doing
that was grammar I scored higher on my
Mac secreto makes my SATs never took the
SATs don't worry that's coming from in
this herbage I scored higher on my math
than my verbal obviously um basically
I'm gonna be doing some more videos on
this channel for you guys which will be
fun if you don't know here's a quick
little synopsis if you don't know much
about me I get distracted very easily
but more importantly than just my own
insecurities and weird pet peeve arees
etc I am a blogger for my damn channel
calm this guy I've vlog every day and
have logged every day for about two
years so if you want to go check that
out you definitely should I defend that
I'm one half of race Michelle I'm the
grace part um look at that there's
nothing and you can go check out all of
our videos on there and this is just an
announcement to let you know that you'll
be seeing some new stuff on this channel
sometimes I mean this is gonna be the
most vague announcement you've ever
heard I will be doing things on this
channel at some point soon ish so until
then thanks for subscribing guys and
I'll see you all soon
ish doing something maybe I don't knows
this is not a settings with the subject
and predicate better at maximum